네, 안녕하세요. 오늘은 제가
13개의 상권을 분석한 자료를 준비를
했습니다. 그래서 여러분들 진짜
서울시에서도 어떤 곳은 반 이상 비어
있고 어떤 곳은 들어가기도 힘들
정도로 꽉 차 있는 건물들이 되게
많은데 13개의 창권의 장단점을 제가
오늘 준비를 했으니까 여러분들 오늘
영상 끝까지 봐 주시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 일단은 데이터를 보여 드릴
건데 제가 계속 줄 얘기했던 것처럼
외국인이 오는 상권만 좀 살아남을 거
같아요. 그래서 지금 아무래도 내수
경기가 매우 안 좋다 보니까 내수
경기 위주로 운영되고 있는 상권은
많이 힘들거든요. 근데 그거와 반해서
외국인들 대상으로 하는 상권들은 지금
굉장히 좋습니다. 작년 같은 경우에는
우리나라를 방문한 외국인 관광객이
무려 1900만 명이나 왔습니다.
그리고 올해는 그거보다 더 높을
것으로 예상이 돼요. 예컨대 한
2천만 명이 넘지 않을까 예상을
합니다. 그래서 제가 좀 본격적으로
상권마다 지표를 좀 보면은 일단 첫
번째로 악구정 로데우 도산공원 그
상권 분석 데이터인데 여기는 공실율이
3%가 좀 안 됩니다. 근데 여기서
보셔야 될게 여기가 앞구정 로데오
블록이 있는 전체를 보는게 아니라
도상공원 인근 그리고 런던베이글을
있는 쪽 미주 데이터라고 보시면 될
거 같아요. 그리고 외국인이 방문하는
순위가 국내 3이라고 합니다. 그리고
여기 도상공원 핵심 라인의 평당
임대료가 60만 원이라고 하는데 지금
이걸 뛰어 넘었어요. 그래서 런던
베이 그리는 쪽에 평당 임대료 최근에
맞춰진 거 보면은 100만 원이
넘습니다. 그 정도로 평당 임대료가
진짜 가파르게 오르고 있어요. 최근
3년간 약 한 20%씩 임대료가 계속
올랐습니다. 네. 그러다 보니까 1등
매매 가격이 계속 오르고 있는 지역
중에 하나입니다. 여기 최근에 클럽
라운지바 수요가 좀 많이 옮겨 갔나
봐요. 그래서 뭐 이태원에 있는 이런
클럽 라운지바가 로데오나 이쪽으로 좀
많이 이전했다라고 합니다. 그리고
최근에 팔린 거 중에 아디다스 입점
있던 건물이 뭐 5년 만에 이제
85억에 샀다가 최근에 뭐 260억에
매각을 했죠. 어떻게 보면 이게 딱
그 결과물인 거 같아요. 임대료가
계속 오르고 있고 최고가 계속
경신하고 있고. 그리고 이제 다른
상권을 좀 보면은 명동은 사실 뭐
말할 것도 없죠. 외국인이 가장 많이
오는 상권이기도 하고. 그리고 여기
또 보셔야 될게 올리브형 오프라인
외국인 구매 1조원이 넘습니다. 어
오프라인 매장에서 이렇게 물론 이제
전체긴 하지만 어 1조원 이상 매출을
내기가 정말 어렵거든요. 예. 말도
안 되는 수치고. 명동 밀리올에 있는
건물 1층에 올리브형이 있거든요.
거기 하루 매출이 얼마지 아세요?
얼만지 아세요?
>> 아니요.
>> 1억이에요. 1억
>> 한 달
>> 하루 하루에 [웃음] 하루 하루에
하루 하루 매출 1억이에요, 여러분.
그래서 그 정도로 올리브형이 지금
난리가 났습니다. 그리고 이제 거기
건너편에 다이소가 있거든요. 여기도
보면은 다이소 외국인 해외 카드
결제이 어 2022년 대비해 가지고
60%가 늘어났어요. 네. 진짜 거기
다소 가면 외국인들 바글바글합니다.
예. 가격이 워낙 경쟁력이 있다
보니까 외국인 관광객들이 진짜 좀
많이 찾는 거 같아요. 영동 상권은
지금 너무 좋습니다. 그리고 이제
한남동 2태원인데 여기도 공실률이
그렇게 높은 편은 아니에요. 그리고
특히 지금이 데이터가 그 꼼대가루
손길 쪽이라고 보시면 될 거 같아요.
그래서 한강직역이랑 이태원역 있는
사이에 있는 그 대로변 그리고 거기
이면에 그 카페거리 쪽에 데이터라고
보시면 될 거 같고 그리고 여기서 또
유심히 보셔야 될게 그 한강진역에
내리는 외국인이 굉장히 많이
늘었습니다. 뭐 전년 대비해서
118%가 늘었어요. 그 정도로
외국인들이 좀 많이 어이 한강진력을
따라서 한남동 카페거리 그리고
꼼대가루 손길를 찾는다라고 보시면 될
거 같아요. 네. 그래서 여기 무신사
스탠더드 건물이 있는데 거기에 외국인
매출 비율이 44%예요. 여기 또
우측 보면은 이면도로까지 상권이 좀
확장되고 있어요. 만약에 내가 한남동
건물 산다라고 하면 한남동 카페
거리를 좀 유심히 보시면 좋을 거
같아요. 그리고 뭐 성수동 이제 말할
거 없죠. 뭐 서울시 내에서 어 제일
핫하다라고 보시면 될 거 같아요.
그래서 외국인 관광객 증가율이 뭐
110% 증가를 했고 외국인 방문객
예상이 한 500만 명이 넘습니다.
그리고 여기 평당 임대료가 영무장길
메인 같은 경우에 명동을 뛰어
넘었어요. 제가 봤을 때 임대료가
받쳐 주는 하는 어 빌딩 가격은 계속
오를 거라고 생각을 합니다. 어
그래서 지금 성수동 뭐 1가 성수동
2가 특히 이제 연무장길 같은
경우에는 공실률이 진짜 너무 낮고
임대는 너무 잘 들어온 상태고 그리고
이제 최고가는 계속 경신하고 있고
평당 임대료는 명동보다 높고 지금
한국에서 가장 뜨거운 상권이라고
보시면 될 거 같아요. 여기도 이제
올리브형 매출이 굉장히 좀 높아졌고
외국인 결제이 전년 대비해서 거의
600%가
올랐어요.이 이 그리고 이제 무신사
스탠더드도 좀 많이 방문하고 있고
밑에 크래프톤이 또 건물 짓고
있잖아요. 그래서 그것도 이제 짓고
하면은 거기 밑에까지 사람들이 많이
갈 거 같습니다. 성수동 같은
경우에는 우리가 가는 외국 관광지들
있잖아요. 그거와 못지 않게 정말
세계적인 관광지로 떠오르지 않았나
그렇게 생각을 합니다. 네. 그리고
이제 청남동 같은 경우에는 전년
대비해서 다행히 공실률이 좀
낮아졌어요. 대부분 보면은이 데이터는
명품거리 위주로 데이터가 산정이 된
거 같고 그래서 명품 전포 비중이 어
상당히 되게 높은 편이고 그리고 명품
거리가 지금 상당히 되게 괜찮아요.
탄탄하고 거기 실제로가 보시면
티파니도 건물 짓고 있고 보테가도
지금 건물 만들고 있고 리모델링 하고
있고 롤렉스도 들어오고 그래서 명품
거리 쪽은 앞으로 좀 더 좋아지지
않을까 그렇게 예상을 합니다. 그거와
반해서 지금 신사동 가로 스킬 같은
경우에는 공실률이 45%라고 하는데
실제로 가서 보면 더 많이 비어
있어요. 그리고 지금 상권 트렌드가
되게 침체 상태고 거기에 유일하게
가로 스킬이 들어가 있는게 애플
스토어 들어와 있죠. 그래서 여기
지금 우측 데이터 보면은 외국인
방문객이 감소하고 있습니다. 컨텐츠가
없는 지금 상황이다 보니까 국내
사람들도 좀 많이 안 찾는 것
같아요. 그래서 여기 지금 신사동
가로 스킬 쪽은 만약에 진입한다
그러면 굉장히 좀 신중하게 진입을
해야 될 거 같아요. 근데 그거와
반해서 세로 습길은 그래도 사람이
조금 있어요. 오히려 그냥 그 세로
스킬 그리고 신사역 그 8번 출구
앞쪽 그쪽 바운더리 정도는 되게
괜찮다라고 생각을 하는데 뭔가
가로스길 그쪽 인근 그쪽 우측으로
가는 거는 지금 상황에서 상건이
그렇게 좀 쉽지 않은 거 같습니다.
그래서 지금 삼성돔 같은 경우에는
GBC 공사하고 있기 때문에 거기
인근의 뭐 상권이 그렇게 좋지
않아요. 그리고 이제 그게 들어와야지
거기 인근 상건까지 좀 좋아질 거라고
생각이 들고 저는 개인적으로
삼성역이란 그 봉은 사역 그쪽이 이제
거의 광화문 광장처럼 될 거예요.
걸어다닐 수 있게 공원화되고 그래서
정말 많은 국내 사람뿐만 아니라
외국인 관광객이 많이 찾을 것
같거든요. 거기 인근의이 LED
광고판도 너무 잘 돼 있어 가지고
진짜 타임스퀘어처럼 우리나라에 오면
꼭 가야 될 그런 관광지 중에 하나가
좀 되지 않을까 그렇게 예상을
합니다. 그리고 GBC가 들어가면
거기 인근의 상권이 좋아질 수밖에
없어요. 그 블록에 어 지금 예를
들면 안공력 인근 같은 경우에는 현대
엔지니어링이나 뭐 건설 사무실
있잖아요. 점심 시간이나 뭐 저녁
시간에 사람이 진짜 많습니다. 여기
지금 GBC에도 물론 그 안에 이제
상권이 있긴 하겠지만 상주 인구가
굉장히 많기 때문에 거기 인근에는
그래도 상권이 좀 좋아질 거다라고 좀
예상이 들고 근데 아무래도 이게 다
지어지려면 시간이 좀 많이 오래 걸릴
것 같아요. 그래서 원래 뭐 28년에
다 짓는다라고 했는데 지금 뭐
2030년 얘기 나오고 있잖아요. 좀
장기 플랜으로 투자 계획을 좀 세워야
될 것 같습니다. 그리고 이제
역삼동인데 오피스 공실이 최적권이라고
하는데 이건 프라임급 빌딩 큰
빌딩들은 어 이렇게 공실율이
낮습니다. 그거와 반해서 거기 이면에
있는 빌딩들은 임대 상황이 좀
[음악] 좋지 않은데 일단이 데이터는
프라임급 빌딩 위주로 좀 데이터가
산정이 된 거 같아요. 사실
역삼동이나 아니면은 지금 다른 지역
뭐 노년동이라든지 대치동 같은
경우에는 외국인이 방문하는 곳은
아니긴 하거든요. 근데 역삼동에서
그나마 이제 강남역이면 이쪽은
외국인이 오긴 하지만 나머지는
외국인이 오는 곳은 아닙니다. 어
여기 상권은 좀 이렇게 국내 위주로
좀 돌아간다라고 보시면 될 거 같고
그리고 또 넘어가서 여긴 또 이제
안국역 인근은 북촌 한옥마을 구글
리뷰가 굉장히 많이 증가를 했고
외국인 관광객이 좀 많이 찾고
있어요. 그래서 제가이 상권을
말씀드리고 싶은게 뭐냐면 우리가 사실
일본 가면은 그냥 호텔에서 자는 것도
있지만 욕한을 가고 싶거든요.
일본에서만 할 수 있는 그런 특색
있는 공간, 특색 있는 상권을 되게
가고 싶어 하는데 외국인도 똑같아요.
그러니까 외국인도 왔을 때 우리나라의
그냥 뭐 일반적인 호텔이 아니라 진짜
한옥께서 축소를 잡고 싶어하고 뭔가
한옥을 보고 싶어 하고 그런 리즈가
있거든요. 그렇다 보니까이 안국역에
있는 뭔가 북촌 한옥마 이쪽을 좀
많이 찾는 거 같아요. 그래서 실제로
평일에도 외국인 관광객이 많고 그리고
주말에도 외국인 관광객이 많이 찾는
그런 관광 명소가 되지 않았나
싶습니다. 지금 안국력뿐만 아니라
이런 뭐 종로 중구에 있는 이런
건물들 보면은 대부분 다 오래되고
건축 규제가 굉장히 많습니다. 그래서
이쪽 지역에 건물 투자한다라고 했을
때 이런 뭐 문화재 보호 지구 용도에
대한 제한도 있을 수 있고 그런
규제들이 있기 때문에 요쪽 지역에
건물 산다 그러면 그런 부분을 잘
체크해서 보시면 좋을 거 같아요.
저희도요 실제로 중계해 보고 임대료를
맞춰보고 있지만 어 임대료 수준이
진짜 많이 올라오고 있습니다. 여기는
사실 대체될 만한 데가 없잖아요. 좀
진짜 콘텐츠가 있는 뭔가이 지역에서만
느낄 수 있는 그런 요소가 있기
때문에 앞으로 외국인 관광객이 계속
많이 오지 않을까 싶습니다. 그리고
홍대 입구역 같은 경우에는 공실률이
좀 낮아졌어요. 네. 그래서 전
분기보다 뭐 계속 좀 낮아지고 있고
어 외국인 관광객이 그래도 완만하게
좀 늘어나고 있긴 해 가지고 홍대
입구역 근처가 그래도 좀 괜찮아지고
있습니다. 홍대 입구역이 공항선까지
연결돼 있어요. 그래서 외국인
관광객들이 여기 게스트하우스를 잡거나
숙소를 좀 많이 잡거든요. 그래도 좀
반가운 소식이죠. 국내 사람들로만
했을 때는 상권이 좀 많이 안
좋아지고 있다가 오늘도 최근에는
조금씩 증가하고 있는 추세라고 보시면
될 거 같습니다. 그리고 이제 삼각
지역 근처 용리단길 쪽 같은 경우에는
직장인들도 좀 많이 오고 그리고
외국인들도 많아지고 있어요. 여기는
뭐 용산 공원 호재도 있고 좀
장기적인 플랜이 좀 필요하긴 해요.
그리고 국제 업무 지구도 들어오고
그래서 여기도 좀 각강받는 그런
상권이라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
그래서 제가 13개의 상권을 좀
이렇게 정리를 했어요. 제가 실제로
막 여기저기 데이터를 긁어 와 가지고
좀 만든 자례고. 어, 여러분들 오늘
영상이 좀 마음에 드셨다면 구독과
좋아요, 알림 설정까지 부탁드리고
그리고이 PPT 자료가 필요하다라고
하시면은 댓글 남겨 주시면은 제가
이메일로 전송을 해 드리도록
하겠습니다. 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다. 감사합니다.